I think you might enjoy some of the
clips I'm going to play for you here
sort of in the way that I enjoy horrible
things which I actually don't so this is
gonna be pretty horrifying we talked
yesterday at the end of the show about
schools reopening or not and Donald
Trump and Mike Pence's desire to see
schools open for what are what are
effectively political reasons Trump
believes schools are being kept closed
in order to hurt him politically now
that's not true but the fact that he
perceives it as political means that
forcing them to reopen is also political
in other words if keeping them closed
hurts him politically opening them he
believes helps him politically Donald
Trump tweeted two days ago in Germany
Denmark Norway Sweden and many other
countries schools are open with no
problems the Dems think it would be bad
for them politically if US schools
opened before the November election but
is important for the families enter for
the children and families may cut off
funding if not open now Trump is saying
we want to be like Europe we want to do
what Europe is doing but the reason
Sweden's not doing so well but Germany
Denmark and Norway the reason they're
doing well is because they handled the
virus completely differently if you want
to be doing what Europe is doing with
schools then you should have handled
coronavirus the way those countries
handled it from the beginning but that's
not really the focus today what we know
today is that cases are up deaths are up
summer camps have around the country in
Arkansas Missouri other places have had
to close because coronavirus outbreaks
have spread among the children and yet
Donald Trump and Mike Pence want schools
open period Trump and pence on Wednesday
at different events both were asked
about opening schools and they were
asked really specific questions about
what are the protocols how do you ensure
safety and their mouths moved and a ton
of stuff came out of their mouths but
they were completely unable or unwilling
to articulate just exactly how you open
schools safely so let's look at some of
these videos let's start with Mike Pence
pence was asked what exactly is the plan
to open school safely pence spoke for
about 90 seconds and he didn't answer
the question I'm going to play the full
answer for you because I want you
to see that he says nothing about the
question that was asked you're going to
hear the question or actually we're
gonna skip though you're not going to
hear the question we're gonna go right
to Mike Pence's answer and notice how
Pence doesn't state anything that would
count as an answer to the question well
the plan is to continue to do what we
have done from the very beginning as you
heard again this morning we're we're at
I believe 39 million tests that have
been performed all across this country
you heard Admiral Jerrod described the
extraordinary commitment in just one
community alone and what we've conveyed
to governor's is whatever support they
need to get kids back to school we're
going to make sure that they have we're
going to make sure that they have the
testing resources we're currently
educating estates on the possibility and
working with commercial labs on the
possibility of what's called pooling so
that literally there could be one test
run on say 10 samples and and there are
there are particularly universities that
already have built into their plans the
idea of testing all of their students at
the beginning of the academic year and
then doing surveillance testing but we
made it very clear whether it's testing
whether it's personal protective
equipment or other resources that we
stand ready to provide those resources
to the states and and we reiterated that
once again to the governor's but the
good news is because of the historic
mobilization that President Trump
initiated we literally have hundreds of
millions of supplies of personal
protective equipment 59,000 ventilators
in the strategic national stockpile
testing is scaling all across America
and we know that come the school year
will be ready to meet those needs so
let's analyze it and go through it Penn
says we're going to do what we've done
from the beginning well you failed that
has failed what you've done from the
beginning is one of the worst Korona
respond to coronavirus responses in the
world trump Penn says we've tested 39
million people over a five-month period
great it's not an answer to how do you
open school safely Penn says we will
give them the support they need
not asking for support they're saying
it's not safe for you to decide that
they have to open and by the way they
failed to give States the support they
needed on testing so why would we trust
them now that they're going to give
schools the support that they need he
says we're looking at pool testing okay
I mean it's not really an answer to the
question he says some universities will
test their students okay he says we'll
send schools PPE if they want it now and
then he says Trump did a historic
mobilization that's a meaningless claim
it's untrue it was a historically bad
mobilization and then pence also
mentions we have ventilators there's not
an answer there because they don't know
how to open schools safely they don't
care if schools open safely they want
schools open in late August early
September with the hope that the that it
won't implode so quickly that they will
get a political benefit going into the
November election that's all they care
about
now CNN's Caitlin Collins had a good
question for pence if the if you insist
that these are decisions to be made
locally by schools why is Donald Trump
pressuring them to open and of course
Mike Pence is completely flummoxed by
the question decision so should it be up
to them to decide if they can safely
reopen and not the president saying he's
going to pressure them to do so well I
look we're gonna respect those unique
communities that may have challenges
that have rising cases or rising
positivity and but I think you look at
the nation as a whole
and what the president in the United
States has made clear as he thinks as we
reopen America we need to reopen America
schools so I think you see where where
that one is going if a community is
unique they get to decide penn says i
guess otherwise trump decides or
something like that and then pence also
says look at the nation as a whole we
had another single day new case record
we had multiple single day new case
records this week that's the nation as a
whole in fact if you want to make a case
for safe reopening you should say let's
not
look at the nation as a whole because
places like Florida and Texas and
Arizona and California and Oklahoma
where cases are spiking like crazy
they shouldn't open maybe you could make
the case that in states that have really
crushed the curve and even those states
I'm worried are going to start seeing
cases now as the numbers nationally go
so high maybe you make the case that you
could take the states that are doing
really well maybe even the counties that
are doing really well and look at
reopening there but when Penn says look
at the nation as a whole the nation as a
whole is setting new records for cases
and then pence also says we also push to
reopen churches as if that's some kind
of justification for opening schools
opening churches was a disaster and in
fact many churches have been a spreader
events spreading a spreader locations
clusters and that's a very bad idea now
then it's Trump Trump just says we have
to do it and everybody wants it Mike
Pence pretends to give an answer even
though he doesn't Trump doesn't even
pretend Trump just says we just have to
do it everybody wants to open so we want
to reopen the schools everybody wants it
the moms want it the dads want it the
kids want it it's time to do it you know
our mortality rate is right now at a
level that people don't talk about but
it's down tenfold tenfold so you look at
deaths are way down from this horrible
China virus and it's a disgrace that it
happened shouldn't have happened but it
did and the economy is coming back and
it's coming back strongly jobs or
setting records for two months ago they
set the record and then again almost
five million new jobs last month which
is a record and it broke our last record
of a month before so the numbers are
happening much faster than anybody
anticipated the stock market Nasdaq just
hit another record today and the markets
generally just really a very small
amount below where they were at the
height of of the market when we first
had to do this about four and a half
five months ago just meaningless
meandering
free association rambling of sorts sites
no evidence that everybody wants it says
the mortality rate is low remember
our death rate per capita is the ninth
highest in the world out of more than
200 countries and territories he says
there are job records he talks about the
Nasdaq or as he pronounces it the Nasdaq
and so between Mike Pence and Donald
Trump over the last 48 hours a lot of
bluster about we've got to open schools
everybody wants the schools open it's
all going to be safe no explanation of
how and why it's safe how they know it's
safe
how safety would be maintained what
would I mean listen another important
question is if these were serious people
who had a plan for how to safely open
then I would move to the question of
what data would say we have to reclose
in other words would it be a certain
number of cases among students what if a
teacher gets a case what if there's a
parent at home with a case is it case
growth rate or absolute numbers what
would be the metrics where you would say
we're going to do it but we're gonna
shut it down if X or Y I mean it's just
it's I'm acting like these are serious
people and that's that that's the
problem last thing I get the importance
of opening schools a lot of parents
can't work if the kids aren't in school
this is huge economically it's gonna be
worse economically if you open schools
and the kids get the virus and the
teachers get the virus and the parents
get the but that will be much worse
economically Tuesday 8:00 p.m. David
Pakman show chess tournament register
for free at david pakman.com slash chess
and remember to get our daily audio
podcast on itunes stitcher
Spotify or whatever your favorite
podcasting app is if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink it's blink Isleta consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction
books condense each one into text or
audio that you can get through in just
15 minutes and you get all of the
important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka stinkiest has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video